ces deux humoristes là se sont
rencontrés il y a plus de 30 ans et
quand Thierry Jardinot et Sully rivière
répète ensemble pour leur prochain
spectacle comme ici à l'espace le compte
de l'île à Saint-Paul ils ont du mal à
rester sérieux nous nous fait les choses
sérieusement on essaye de ne pas rire
mais c'est vrai que quand il fait son
personnage
[Musique]
pour son spectacle intitulé gramoun
connection Thierry Jardinot fort de ses
40 ans de scènes a eu carte blanche avec
les théâtres départementaux ce show il a
imaginé comme des retrouvailles avec des
gramouns comme il dit
beaucoup de complicité et on a pris ce
qu'on a
avec un petit peu de temps mais
aujourd'hui
sur scène il y aura aussi gabyle iTunes
et sont ses gammes maloya longtemps pour
une ambiance orchestre bal créole dont
Thierry Jardinot et fans
[Musique]
ça me fait plaisir de retourner avec
jardinier parce que je connais pas si
c'est le dernier spectacle qu'on va
faire avec puisque là chaque fois je
suis très content à côté de l'ancienne
génération la nouvelle le coup de cœur
musical de l'humoriste
[Musique]
rapporte la musique aussi dans son mode
sketch et comme à moins bien secret
Jardinot aussi embarqué sa complice
celle qui l'accompagne chaque matin pour
sa chronique en radio mais pense que par
les temps qui courent les biens de
passer une soirée ou nous ça rire ou
s'amuser nous ça chantait une ça
retrouve les chansons que nous connaît
forcément que la résidence la tête tu es
obligé dit oui obligé Thierry Jardinot
entouré de ses dalons et dalon de sa
femme et de son fils aussi pour gramme
une connection c'est le 30 juin et le
1er juillet au Théâtre plein air de
Saint-Gilles
[Applaudissements]
aussi
mettez encore la passer nous continuons
l'ambiance avec Thierry Jardinot et Emma
Nonna en plateau bonsoir à tous les deux
bonsoir alors déjà grammoune connexion
pourquoi parce que tout simplement nous
prendre l'âge que ce soit sur
la grammouture donc M'a voulu faire un
spectacle pendant plus longtemps un peu
de vitalité un spectacle ensemble
puisque nous les rares que nous les
ensemble donc Madame Monday mon avis de
Gaby m'a invite Sully Benoît fait un
spectacle rire rire et chansons créole
c'est gars des années 80 ambiance Sega
oui
gabyle a été mon
idole Sega depuis très longtemps quoi
comment était jeune moi tu es pas bonne
10 33 heures boum c'était gabyle avec
une elle est sous le même et là mon rêve
c'était vraiment je dois partager la
scène avec lui m'a eu quelques occasions
mais comme ça là non c'est là vraiment
la première fois et ma Nouna comment on
la retrouve à ola dedans
mais remis à aller d'ailleurs c'est un
grand lonium pour moi de fait partie de
cette carte blanche là de pouvoir
partager la musique maloya nous
tradition Sega tout ça là avec 20
gramoun comme Gaby comme Sully c'est
vraiment à l'oignon pour moi et où on
fait la musique dans ce spectacle non
peut-être ah peut-être et tu es riche
chante il danse aussi dans la non
méchante pas vraiment chi peut-être un
peu un petit peu mais c'est calmé ça qui
chante surtout
[Rires]
non non mais c'est vrai un vrai mélange
un spectacle rire et musique quoi et
rivière il parle de complicité entre
autres qui va chanter il va chanter
parce que nous on va remémore un peu les
années balles bah longtemps avec les
orchestres de la Réunion et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il y a été champion de balle
avant d'être humoriste Sully donc il va
Renaud avec ses premières amours de
toute façon et qui nous va retrouver
dans ce spectacle comme personnage comme
sketch un petit peu ah ben n'aura des
grands mound voilà bon on aura le grand
moun torby et puis on aura la passerelle
avec Isabelle puisque nous on va faire
ça en live pour une fois comme
partenaire nous rentrent nous la radio
et nous la radio le matin mais là ce
sera sur scène puisque avant c'était une
voix off que vous utilisez de la part
d'Isabelle mais là ça sera là en vrai
donc et puis suivi va jouer sur mon
sketch de gramoun et moi moi je vais me
manque deux grammes parce que le
spectacle est intitulé Cameroun
connection et bien la connexion elle a
marché tout de suite entre tout ce monde
là ah oui oui parce que nous partage la
même par rapport à ça et les mêmes
émotions parce que il évoque les mêmes
souvenirs nous a connu à peu près la
même période le seul brin de jeunesse de
danse avec quelques musiciens que néna
et puis Emma et Emma est-ce que ou la ou
il a été surprise par la demande de
Thierry ou tu en as où il a dit oui tout
de suite comment ça se passe un petit
peu
à moi et puis elle a commencé cause à
moins 40 blanche tout ça là m'a même pas
réfléchi moi j'allais lui directement
parce que mais après c'est bon on pèse
que les faits et le fait que lui apporte
lui apporte à moins là dedans lire à la
main là-dedans et moi elle est content
fait partie de ce spectacle il fait
partie de ce spectacle là et justement
Thierry qui dit aussi bah il a eu un
coup de cœur c'est ce que nous attendons
dans le reportage pour pour emmanonner
et ce côté
voilà créole que vous mettre en avant le
côté fraîcheur jeunesse dans cette
grande connection parce que c'est la
relève mais pense dans dans la branche
maloya Sega voilà c'est la nouvelle
scène réunionnaise qui lève et donc
voilà profitez de ça pour voilà
rafraîchir un peu le spectacle parce que
grand moule mais des grammouths
sera donc le 30 juin et le premier
juillet théâtre Saint-Gilles là-bas et
est-ce que nous peut demander de finir
en musique alors oui ben moi comme
chanteur
c'est le 30 juin et le 1er juillet au
Théâtre plein air de Saint-Gilles voilà
c'est ça et classe à la musique asterne
ma passion passe croirons-nous l'amour
[Musique]
[Rires]
prochain au Théâtre Saint-Gilles pour la
gramoun connection merci Thierry merci